[Música]
en 1849 en el sitio de la antigua ciudad
de nínive en el norte de Irak un equipo
de arqueólogos examinaba unas ruinas
polvorientas esperando encontrar algo
que probara la veracidad de las
historias bíblicas en cambio encontraron
una de las bibliotecas más antiguas del
mundo
inscrita en tablillas de arcilla
deteriorada se encontraba una historia
de 4000 años de antigüedad tan
apasionante que la primera persona que
las tradujo se desbordó de la emoción
la llamada epopeya de gilgamesh comienza
con gilgamesh rey de la ciudad de uruk
que se presentaba sin invitación en las
bodas para dormir con la novia antes de
que pudiera hacerlo su esposo
Para calmar a gilgamesh la diosa aruru
le creó un rival llamado enkidu
vivía fuera de los muros de la ciudad
donde reinaba el caos y merodeaban
animales salvajes Invasores y espíritus
malignos cuando una de las sacerdotisas
de la diosa Star sedujo a enkilu los
animales salvajes lo rechazaron Y
entonces enkido se aventuró a la ciudad
allí encontró a gilgamesh haciéndolo de
Siempre
en kidu intervino para detenerlo
el combate entre los dos fue muy parejo
y lucharon por las calles de la ciudad
hasta que gilgamesh ganó por un pelo
a partir de ese momento fueron
inseparables con su nuevo amigo
gilgamesh abandonó su interés por las
novias de uruk y se concentró en
demostrar su fuerza en el combate
partieron para asesinar a hunbabá una
criatura de mil caras que custodiaba el
bosque de los cedros
lo rastrearon y le hicieron gran
emboscada acorralado jumbaba suplicó por
su vida y luego los maldijo mientras
gilgamesh daba el último golpe de vuelta
en uruk la diosa Easter le declaró su
amor a gilgamesh
sabiendo que la diosa solía perder
interés y maldecir a sus viejos amantes
gilgamesh rechazó sus avances en Represa
liberó al toro del cielo para que
destruyera las cosechas y matar a gente
en uruk cuando
gilgameshienkidu mataron al toro en
defensa de la ciudad los dioses mataron
a henkido entró en la casa del polvo el
oscuro Inframundo de la Mesopotamia
donde los Espíritus de los muertos se
arrodillaban Eternamente y comían tierra
y bebían piedras
afligido por la muerte de en kidu y
aterrado de correr la misma suerte
gilgamesh emprendió el rumbo Más allá de
las montañas cósmicas en busca de la
inmortalidad encontró hombres
escorpiones y árboles de piedras
preciosas pasó por debajo de las
montañas y corrió más rápido que el sol
hasta que finalmente llegó al final del
mundo donde encontró una taberna
la tabernera una diosa llamada
gilgamesh que abandonara su búsqueda y
le dijo que todos los mortales estaban
destinados a morir pero que debía
disfrutar de su vida hasta que le
llegara la muerte pero gilgamesh no
quiso darse por vencido a regañadientes
shiduri le indicó como cruzar las aguas
de la muerte para encontrarse con
adnapisty el hombre inmortal los dioses
le habían concedido la inmortalidad
atnapisty luego de un gran diluvio
durante el cual había construido un arca
cargado animales y desembarcado en una
montaña
adnapisty también alentó a gilgamesh a
aceptar que la muerte llegaba para todos
pero gilgamesh insistió abnnapisty le
dijo entonces que si conseguía vencer el
sueño tal vez los dioses le concederían
la inmortalidad
gilgamesh trató de mantenerse despierto
durante siete días pero se quedó dormido
inmediatamente
le dijo de una planta mágica que crecía
en el fondo del océano y otorgaba la
eterna juventud
si bien gilgames pudo encontrar la
planta una serpiente se la robó en el
camino de regreso a casa pero cuando
gilgamesh volvió a ver su hermosa ciudad
hizo las paces con su mortalidad y juró
pasar el resto de su vida haciendo
grandes logros
escribió su historia en una tablilla de
lapislázuli y la enterró debajo de las
murallas de la ciudad para que futuras
generaciones la encontraran y
aprendieran de ella las tablillas
encontradas en nínive pertenecían a la
biblioteca del Rey asirio asiurmanipal
si bien la historia es un mito gilgamesh
fue probablemente un rey de uruk las
distintas versiones de esta historia
datan del año 2000 antes de Cristo o
incluso antes pero aún están presentes
en la literatura de nuestros días
maestros lleven a sus escuelas los
materiales gratuitos de las charlas para
estudiantes de Ted y denles a sus
estudiantes la oportunidad de expresar
sus pasiones a través del arte de la
narración de historias obtenga más
información y comience en
et.t.com/ español barra materiales